the censorship actually work meaning a
company decides to censor a person and
ID on issue
does it give that person less
credibility but does it give that idea
more credibility for example you're
sitting there you're watching a video on
your phone you're at work you're at your
house you're in the car you're in the
bathroom you're in bed you're watching
this video oh wow interesting huh that's
crazy all of a sudden the video doesn't
play is this my wife I let me check let
me check my wife's baby let me see here
babe it doesn't come up on your phone
let me take 17 of my friends did you
guys see this video was taken down no no
no then you go on Facebook did anybody
see this video was taken out by
such-and-such then you go on linked and
then you go on Twitter then you go on
Instagram 642 people saw you post this
then they go search they go on Google
they go on YouTube they go on Facebook
and they see it's taken down then 30,000
people see it then 300,000 people see
then three million people see it then 30
million people see it did the company
censoring the individual the idea or the
issue give it more credibility or less
did they make it a non-issue or even a
bigger issue what happens think about it
right so some people are saying I think
these major companies are censoring
people etc etc okay this is not a
black-and-white issue by the way this is
very great the censorship topic is a
very great because you got the
government censoring which is a major
issue like China you got a government as
censoring which you cannot do in u.s.
because you have the freedom of speech
and press government cannot do that no
matter how much Trump hates CNN he can't
shut down CNN it's Free Press no matter
how much Trump wishes everybody in his
conferences he does when he's doing Q&A
with everybody he wishes everybody was
just from the side that agreed with him
he can't do it even though he's the most
powerful man in the world he doesn't
control free press right he can't the
government cannot do that now
corporations with censorship is a
different story couple weeks ago dr.
Judy Mike Ovitz was taken down some of
you guys are probably watching it's
because you watch my response my
response got somewhere on 750,000 views
you guys agreed a lot of you guys agreed
but many of you also disagreed and you
came back saying I cannot believe Pat's
part of the New World Order I bet you
they can't contacted him and they've
given him money behind closer he's part
of the CIA he's probably been connected
or I got the strangest messages here
about censoring my opinion because I
said I really you know if you two wants
to do that you two can do that but
there's consequences to it so what do
you mean by that let me explain Jordan
Belfort and I are doing a facebook like
Instagram live a couple weeks ago you
can actually see it on Facebook on
YouTube and he's going on and he's is
upset with the fact that censorship you
can't talk about this you can't talk
about that coronavirus California
shutting down I can't believe what
they're he's he's obviously upset for
valid reasons state of California some
of the decisions they're making just
makes no sense we're gonna keep a close
till August doesn't make sense what a
lot of things they're doing but again
I'm listening to me speaking ninety-five
percent of time then he says why are you
not concerned about us I'm not concerned
about says why don't you why are you not
concerned about I said because the
biggest way like what you don't want to
do it's bully an audience
you can't censor an audience you give
them such a major backing I'll give you
a few examples in Iran Reza Shah Pahlavi
the king of Iran when I was born he was
still running around before he went in
exile after Khomeini took it over he was
frightened of a group called today today
were the Communists he was frightening
of them and he would do anything he
could to try to shut these guys down he
was so afraid of him right
Saavik all this other stuff what that
did is it gave them more power and more
power why because naturally were rebels
you're a rebel how many people are just
yes yes yes yes yes most people or not
there are a lot of people that have the
rebellious moaning so imagine somebody
tells you don't read that what do you do
you go read it somebody says to sound
like my son imagine I tell my kids don't
go partying these are bad David's what
do you think they're gonna do okay dad
we're now gonna go part taking a good
party hey don't use drugs they're gonna
use drugs don't drink alcohol they're
gonna do because that's in our bones you
had it I have it it's a part of us when
when somebody decides to shut down and
idea when somebody says shut down an
idea it may seem like a good idea like a
good idea at the beginning you're given
it so much more power sometimes it's not
even necessary sometimes the issue would
have disappeared but because you're not
doing it you're given more and more
weight and credibility I'll go a little
bit deeper
Jordan Belfour and I are talking he says
how come you're not worried I said first
of all let me say this upfront I said
this to Prager and I said it to Jordan
Belfort I said it's all Republicans
fault what I mean it's all Republicans
fault it's all Republicans fault how
could you say that Republicans didn't do
anything wrong I said it's all there
they're crying they're upset oh my gosh
look at this you know all the Democrats
and the Liberals on all of social media
Facebook YouTube Google Amazon Bezos
bought Washington Post you know the guy
from Salesforce by Time magazine
you got LA Times you got New York Times
yeah this is just too much we don't have
a voice we wish we had a voice Fox
even Fox his sons are taken over they're
both Democrats boxes going to one side
what should we do what should we do
Republicans if you're watching your
party chase the dollar Democrats they
chased controlling the narrative and
audience when you control an audience
you dictate the next 50 years when you
chase money without an audience no one
cares there are billionaires in America
that can send a tweet nobody cares
because they just have money and there
are people that are broke that send one
tweet 700,000 people would listen to
that tweet one controls narrative one
has money the Republicans could about
Twitter for six billion dollars they
didn't the Republicans could about
hourly attempts or 550 million dollars
they didn't the Republicans could about
Time magazine for 350 million dollars
they didn't it's your fault what are you
upset about why are you so upset you
could have done all that stuff you
didn't so you can't blame Democrats
Democrats are strategic I give them
credit
I give them very a lot of credit for
what they're doing strategically
politically I'm a capital
you already notice if you watch my
content register white I'm an
independent
I voted Clinton avoided right I'm
registered independent for the last six
seven eight years because there are
certain things I see both sides as games
but you can't city or said oh my gosh
they're controlling my voice tell your
party to go create social media
platforms tell your party to go buy some
damn media companies tell your party to
control the narrative is also they can
fight few guys try to do it the rest of
them are not tell your younger party all
of these small younger community go
start some technology companies you're
not you're telling them gold beer this
no compete so I don't have any problem
with the competition and Democrats
controlling the media and the narrative
today because they invested in the
narrative this that invested into
businesses very big difference I'll give
you another part here that's the flip
side of what I just said right now so
dr. Judy Mike Ovitz I'm a pro max my
kids get backs and bothell I'm not even
one of those probe axes that are
secretly anti-vaxxers our kids we've
never said no to single vaccine our kids
have ever gotten ever okay now I'm an
adult I'm 41 I'm about debate
I love having debates I love sitting
down and talking to my kids about
debates what do you think about this
what do you think about that
if you work with me it's all a debate
every day if I'm having a conference
call it's a debate all the tell him
alright this it's oh I'm my DNA it's all
debate everything is debate with me
why because two ideas clash of better
idea comes out so dr. Judy comes on a
kind of interesting some of the stuff
she says pretty outlandish
Butare some stuff he says pretty
outlandish some of the stuff is let me
go to my own research Robert F Kennedy
how interesting okay let me go do my own
research so one of the guys I like a lot
on social media is dr. Mike I love his
channel dr. Mike good-looking 30 year
old doctor very eloquent talks very well
seems very reasonable and fair and he
had dr. Fauchon on his chatting his
channel has like 10 million subs right
if you have not subscribed to it it's a
phenomenal Channel I like the stuff that
he does so we have contacted a lot of
people Paul off to do a probe axe I
wanted to have him as a guest no ha
whets is there Peter Hodes I believe dr.
P no okay no problem I totally
understand you don't have to say yes you
choose
but we contact dr. Mike within five
minutes absolutely let's do it great my
Booker everything we're going back and
forth and then I contact dr. Judy are
you open to it let me first do a little
bit of research her answer was an
immediate yes it was let me first see
she go she does research great
she says I'm in I watched the video
because dr. Mike did a video calling out
we should put the link of the video as
well he calls out dr. chu should go
watch it by yourself he does a very good
job he calls out dr. Judy says she's
wrong here she's wrong there that's
normal this is not true you can't say
that and I'm like oh wow
30-minute video put a lot of time and
effort into it's a phenomenal video so
he says yes then yesterday our Booker
contacts a sense doctor might cancel
with the no explanation I went on
Instagram I messaged him haven't
resizing hasn't gone to respond back but
it's been 24 hours
I said hey dr. Mike I was excited about
you being on because I wanted to give a
lot of credence to have you guys talked
to one another he was open to him and
dr. Judy being on together no response
so now watch this he said yes he changed
his mind
why so me let me be a little bit
skeptical and going assume what things
could have potentially happened
number one I'm busy I just don't have
time give me a break it's a 2.3 million
Channel sub you can come to value Tim
Ian you have another exposure it'll give
you more eyeballs set that one aside
another one I don't want to get on
because I just don't want to share my
content right now because it seems
controversial when you did the video
callin or out you said you were willing
to do something like this why did you
change your mind so now somebody like me
who is always questioning things I sit
and I say why don't you want to do the
interview what's the big deal
maybe you're now a little bit concerned
that maybe she does have some
credibility because two of our books our
top 15 on New York Times bestseller list
they're constantly selling out because
they can't sell enough of them I'm part
of the same publishing from a publishing
house with Simon & Schuster why doesn't
dr. Mike why did he change his mind
now to give respect to off and the ho s
when we contacted them their immediate
answer was absolutely no fine
I respect us immediately was what no why
did dr. Mike go from yes to no why see
that makes me give more credibility to
dr. Judi because he said yes then he
backed out it's kind of like this if you
watch UFC there's this documentary 34:31
it's Ortiz against what'd he call it
Chuck Chuck Liddell and by the way I'm a
fan of Chuck and I'm a fan of Ortiz one
time we play poker at a charity event
with Ortiz you remember was with Tiger
Woods and Westbrook and all these guys
Phil Hellmuth we had a great time
tito is a real cool guy but I'm watching
the documentary and there's a scene
where Chuck and Tito are coming up
together and Ortiz is Connick constantly
touring down a fight about wanting to
fight Chuck Liddell and Ortiz it's about
money look how much money they're making
this is money I'm holding back because
when we do it they got it really pairs
because Dana doesn't pay well finally
they do the deal when
dude it took like a couple years finally
they do the deal when they do the deal
Chuck Liddell knock them out not even
close
they fought again the second time Tito
did a little bit better second time
Chuck Liddell knocked him out again
maybe Chuck was better the entire time
now I know the last fight when they
fought they were older all that others
have a lot of people say should never
happen Dana said should never happen sit
that part I said at their prime Chuck B
Tito maybe Chuck was right maybe Tito
didn't want to face off Chuck maybe some
of these guys talk a big game but they
don't want to do a debate I'm a dr. Mike
fan I was looking forward to this
because I think the audience needs to
see both sides clash a little bit and
talk we become smart smarter he didn't
do it why not he said a foul Qi on his
channel that may be foul it's not a good
idea I don't know all this stuff is
speculation but the point is the more
they censor an idea or an issue it
doesn't work you give it so much weight
you see I had a call with one of our
competitors I sent something something
out the other day to my competitors
because in the insurance industry were
competing heavily and we had a very big
month last month and this month
record-breaking month in the first 15
days we did more than we did last year
in the fur in the 31 days by a mile it's
just a massive month we're having our
investment bankers are you know bored no
one cannot can't even believe the
numbers are coming up so I put a tweet
out and I said here's a message to my
competitors three people send me
messages saying this person said this
about you on a conference call and this
lady said this about you in a meeting
publicly in front of people I said no
problem
so then I sent a tweet up and I said
here's a message to my competitors in
the insurance industry I'm a nice guy
but I have a very good memory I have
value tenors in every company even my
enemies there are people in the company
that love us and what we create and I'm
somebody that you don't want to create
an enemy with not a threat because I
don't forget things and I always come
back and want to surprise you
it's my approach it sound wired I wish I
wasn't this way believe me your life
would probably be a lot more peaceful
when I watch the neck the last dance and
I see Mike holds a grudge he goes after
this person he's wired that way he
wishes you
that way because you would probably have
a better life but that's the wiring
right okay now watch this say you censor
somebody's message or an issue say you
do and that person is extremely
extremely confident in what they're
doing and determined and ambitious to
the point that they don't forget don't
you think people like that creative
following and don't you think they're
gonna continue until their mission is
accomplished
say you censor this person there are 20
people around them that have already
been infected by this person's
conviction that 20 goes to 40 80 160
censoring this message officially gave
power and there's now an underground
community being built that underground
community is gonna do their part to make
sure that message gets hurt how long is
that gonna take it's irrelevant it's
irrelevant it's irrelevant they're
eventually gonna be hurt mandela goes to
prison for 20-some years it doesn't
matter it's brewing you're just brewing
this person to come out you try to push
MLK around you're doing it to the wrong
guy
the wrong guy you cannot do this to
people
eventually the message is gonna come out
so for some of you out there I don't
even want to call you hater I just think
you're somebody that's a critic and came
out what you said about what I said I
told it told by the way if there's
anything I don't mind I def I just
interviewed a communist totally agree
with everything he said you know what
happened by the time I was done
interviewing this communist I ended up
liking him because I understand I can
like a person and hate an idea there are
many times I love the idea of a person
but I can't stand them you ever met
somebody you agree with philosophically
but they're so unknowing you ever met
some I like that and you ever met
anybody that you can't stand what they
believe in
but you love them you'd love to have a
drink with them that's also with ideas
and people sometimes we get too
emotionally caught up and we forget
that's about this we have to look at
this you're right
so look this is a ranch what I am saying
to you is long-term censorship doesn't
work and don't be naive to think that
we're just creating a youtube channel
here you know we love where we are we
love what we're doing but there's a
vision we're doing this with a fish
there's a lot of big things happening
the future looks bright there's a lot of
people that want to make an impact
there's a lot of people that want to do
big things there's a lot of people from
both sides out of contacting us I have a
lot of people in media that are friends
of ours that are Democrats that love our
content and they disagree with many
areas of it I have a lot of friends in
media that are Republicans that love our
content but they still disagree with
many of the things I talk about it's
okay
that's how we get better so the next
time a media platform censors again it's
going to happen why don't you go to your
party and ask them how come they're not
creating more media platforms huh
why not how much do you want to be a
victim and saying we don't control 95%
of media it's out there it's called
capitals we'll go buy it go create it
how come you're not because you just
focused on money maybe it's time you
spent some of your billions of dollars
Republicans and you also decide to
create some media companies so six hours
after shooting this video not uploading
or shooting this video dr. Mike got back
to me on Instagram and he said you know
I never said I agreed to do the
interview I said I'll think about it but
your book or harass me now that's what
he said right let me tell you my
Booker's resume so you kind of have an
idea who my Booker is look I've been in
the sales business for a while and I
know what harassment is and it's done to
me all the time we get it because they
want me to be interviewed on a bunch of
different places and there's annoying
wave Booker's do things so I fully
understand what he's saying so I want to
contact on my Booker here's my resume my
Booker 22-year CBS okay
22 years CBS wanted their main Booker's
he's been our Booker for about three and
a half years he's one of my four
Booker's that I have he's probably the
best one I have right now watch this for
three and a half years not one time has
any talent been upset with him ever not
one time not one time has any talent
they've been upset with them here's the
second thing you need to know about my
Booker
when my Booker sends us a message and
says the talent says yes no talent has
ever changed his mind dr. Mike is
officially the first one if you wanted
to make history officially did he's the
first one to back out by the way my
Booker's version of the story because I
don't like if somebody that represents
my brand insults talent because I fired
Booker's in the past before because you
cannot talk to talent in a bad way I
have a lot of respect for talent because
they're busy days busy lives there are
things they need to do if they wanna
make time to be guests on my team it
just like if I make time to be on other
platforms as a guest I want respect so
if they've done that they've been fired
I've never once had an issue with my
Booker not one time we said what
happened with them he says we can take
my Booker says I talked him on the phone
three times talk three times are you
sure yes you sure you know you're gonna
do this yes so when he sends us a
message he got three confirmations from
dr. Mike the doctor Mike wanted to do it
then dr. Mike when they're booking the
time then two days later he changes his
mind
on the message he says I was harassed he
says but when I talk to my team my team
said you're too busy to do an interview
right now
too busy to do an interview you're a
doctor you watched all the interviews of
the doctors that you showed all of them
you said you watched all along that's
about seven hours of content and you had
enough time to rebuttal and you had
enough time to upload and you are too
busy to do an interview and face the
person you call that you called her out
just certainly I mean let's just say you
could if I call somebody out anybody
come sit next to me let's talk you don't
put a camera on I'm good if I called you
if I called you out that's just called
basic mannerism of calling somebody out
don't call somebody out if you don't
want to face him you called her out
you've been given a request dr. Judy
didn't say yes immediately she said let
me have watched the video she watched
your video then she said yes you
canceled after saying yes three times I
don't know why I don't know the whole
story there's many things to speculate
but that's the audience's ability to go
out and speculate and know what happened
because you were invited and then I told
him he says well I'm so busy my
kitchen was so busy folks I have a wife
I'm married I have three kids and eight
a six or three-year-old I run a company
with 15,000 agents I have multiple
investors De La Hoya's Gabrielle
Brenner's Atalaya
you're great I have so many people I got
a board meeting regularly carry your
meetings with AIG is National Life Group
all these major insurance companies I
create content I interview people just
last week three interviews when I that's
research you got to do content you got
to put together a shoot I'm working out
we got 168 hours in a week I think you
have time to do it and if you watch his
Instagram he doesn't have kids he's just
a guy that's a single good-looking guy
that's a good doctor that he's got a big
presence I think he has time I'm not
speculating on why he canceled I have no
idea but I suggest if you want to go ask
him value Tanner's you may want to go
ask them some tells me he's gonna say he
was harassed but I'd love to see
definition of harassment show us what
happened to harass you because in
three-and-a-half years of doing business
with my Booker I've never once heard any
talent big talent billionaires
politicians press we got a names on top
of names a celebrities have a never one
time had any talent to be upset with my
Booker specifically this one so that was
the rebuttal to him getting back to us I
didn't want this video to go up without
telling you that he did at least respond
on Instagram to my message and I still
recommend you go watch the video because
it's still a very good video he put up
I'm gonna put the link below as well
thanks so much for watching everybody
take care what do you think I'm curious
comment below